okay these women and young girls are
learning self-defense it's one of a
number of initiatives launched by the
Indian government after 23 year old
trainee physiotherapist Jyoti Singh was
fatally injured from a gang rape and her
way home from the cinema since the
attack the number of rape cases in the
country has rocketed police say one is
reported every 20 minutes number of
complaints has gone up because we've
encouraged women to come they are not
coming freely to the police station they
are going straight to the women's l desk
and they are lodging their complaints it
is being recorded as it is by the
officers the brutal attack led to mass
protests across the country with women
saying they felt they couldn't report
crimes because the police weren't
interested somehow this case are really
struck us because it could have been any
one of us that it happened to right I
mean we could have watched the movie
gotten into an auto or a cab now a new
laws being passed which means officers
who fail to register sex offences could
be jailed for up to three years but
jockeys parents say it's more than
legislation that's needed is there's no
gun on river earth up were to us there's
one thing that hasn't changed is our
society it's very important to change
people's attitudes to women this can
only happen from with it over here
memorial services for jati took place
across the world in london campaign is
gathered outside the Indian High
Commission to lay white roses and ring
bells in tribute to the dead student in
Delhi schoolchildren lit candles and
made artwork to symbolize women's rights
but in another part of the city a group
of men gathered to oppose the new
anti-rape laws saying they're prone to
misuse legality say but today we feel
scared to even talk to a girl do you a
little weak I feel none of us are going
to employ a female secretary because if
a complaint was lodged against us we'd
be imprisoned you guys know dagger a
mediator point I agree that the number
of rapes in India has increased but
someone must draw a line it's about
there's an a
with more female officers responding to
complaints and the issue being widely
debated campaigners say they're pleased
changes are being made but that there's
still a long way to go before women feel
safe and fully supported by police who
ignored them in the past Chloe Copeland
Sky News